how to get started at a young age with
no money
so i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
exxon who wrote in to say hey evan first
of all i love your videos and i watch
them every day you're a role model for
me and you inspire me a lot every day
thank you exxon that's great i'm almost
20 years old i live in germany
my question is how to get started in the
real estate business especially in the
house apartment rental business i'm
learning studying every day about real
estate
it's my passion i found for myself how
do i get started at my young age
without having a lot of money because
buying a house requires a lot of money
as you know
i know i could work in a business as
you've told us in one of your videos to
get some experience but how do i get
started in that business in a young age
without
any money ps keep doing what you're
doing because you inspire me you're
doing great in what you do oven love
your videos they push me forward and i
learn a lot from them by
exile so this is great i love your
enthusiasm i love your passion
i love that you found what you love to
do and you're pushing forward on it
listen you need to go get some
experience
okay your best bet now is not just to
read and not just to watch the videos i
mean keep watching videos
that's great especially if you love them
but
go find somebody who's doing exactly
what you want to do
who is building these kinds of
businesses who is buying up the
apartments who are buying up the houses
and has built
a business doing it it's not just an
individual investor but has
a business and has a team and go work
for them go
learn the ropes from them have this
person be a mentor so you know what
what it takes you know what it looks
like to run a successful company doing
this
you know how they evaluate a property
how they finance it
how they bring on investors how they
market it right
who's on their team how they make
decisions all of that stuff
you want to learn as quickly as possible
and as low risk as possible because if
you're out
you go but you don't have a lot of money
right you go buy your first house you go
buy your first apartment if you make a
mistake on it
you're sunk man right like that first
one that's important stuff for you
and so you want to make sure that when
you're out there doing it yourself
you're not making
mistakes go make your mistakes by
learning from somebody else okay
the education you're gonna get from them
will also shortcut your path
so instead of you taking 10 years to
figure this all out yourself you're
taking somebody's
knowledge from the past 20 30 years of
their experience
and in three six eight months you're
bringing it
absorbing it because i get the sense
you're gonna absorb this stuff pretty
quick
you're internalizing it so when you go
out and make decisions you hit the
ground running
okay so go out and find that person even
if it's part time just to learn and get
that mentorship
the other thing to keep in mind is this
doesn't have to be all your money
okay you don't have a lot of money you
don't need a lot of money
a lot of these guys they get investors
so how do you then find investors
and have the credibility right you're
not even 20 years old how do you have
the credibility and how do you have the
confidence right if you're going and
asking people for money and saying hey
you're going to make a great return on
this
you got to know that it's going to work
how do you get that confidence when
you've never done it before
that's why getting the experience even a
little bit of experience working with
somebody
who has a track record who will teach
you things
so that when you're ready to go launch
yourself and you find a great deal in an
apartment or a house
maybe the first one is a split joint
venture with with your mentor
or maybe when you go out and you start
looking for investors it's not just your
name but also the mentor's name on top
of it so there's extra added security on
it
right it doesn't have to be all your
money you can break out of that mindset
because if you're starting from nothing
it can take a long time to build up to
getting enough to buy an apartment
complex
right that's a lot of cash but again a
lot of these guys don't use their own
money for everything
you may put a little bit of your own in
then you get investors and then you
charge your management fee
you charge your management fee on top of
everything that comes in
so you're earning an additional
percentage or two or whatever it is you
figure it out they're best models to
practice to look at
but the money doesn't always have to be
a hundred percent
yours again you got to decide are you in
this just as a
passive you know investment thing on the
side
where you're off then having a job or
doing a different business or are do you
want to turn this into a business
right do you want to have lots of houses
lots of apartments
a management team to run everything
because if you're going to do that then
you got to look at how do i get capital
and breaking out of the mindset that it
all has to be your own
is going to help you explode this
business forward so those are my two
bits of advice again recap go find the
mentor work for somebody who's done this
make make your mistakes on somebody
else's dime let them teach you the ropes
and then two when you find your first
place
bring on investors charge your
management fees so you're not just doing
it all yourself
you have some experience using other
people's money and whatever you have for
yourself
and you build it up from there i'm
excited for you good luck let me know
how it goes keep me posted with your
progress
and believe for those of you watching
let me know what you think if you've
done anything in the real estate
business you have something to add to
this video please leave it in the
comments below it'll help
inspire other people as well you like
this video give it a thumbs up
and you can click on my face to
subscribe to the channel see more videos
like this
thank you so much i'll see you soon